grim Ock's is a ranger built to control
the battlefield and neutralize enemies
his array of abilities reward precision
play and allow him to lock down and
destroy high-value targets focus on
buying cards that increase your energy
damage and critical strike chance grim
Ock's has a ton of utility built into
his kit this placement blast fires an
energy ball that knocks enemies away
from the explosion use this to displace
your targets or to knock away incoming
threats deflector shield will emit a
bubble that absorbs an incoming spell
when timed correctly this ability can
get you out of bad situations even enemy
Ultimates suppression mode will cause
enemies you hit to be slowed this is a
powerful tool that allows you to stick
to targets it can even be used to slow
incoming threats and finally grim X's
ultimate gyro targeted for sword or GTFO
will fire a long-range homing bolt it
will track down its target wherever they
go when playing grim Ock's you decide
when it's time to fight use your
abilities to dismantle enemy engagements
slow down targets and displace enemy
damage dealers once you spot your victim
use GTFO to vaporize your target
you